[Música]
en el mundo relajado de la moda con
frecuencia los diseñadores libaneses
siempre han hecho gala de ostentación un
saber hacer artesanal inigualable
volcado en especial hacia arabia saudita
emiratos árabes unidos y estados unidos
pero actualmente la crisis económica la
pandemia y sobre todo la explosión en el
puerto de virú en agosto de 2020 no
quedaron esta economía muy lucrativa
grandes apellidos de beirut los
diseñadores rabih kayrouz y su hair
murat tuvieron que suspender su
actividad otros tuvieron más suerte como
elie saab o tony wayne quienes sólo
sufrieron perjuicios materiales unos
cuantos meses después de la tragedia
decidieron dar su testimonio estábamos
trabajando porque debíamos entregar
vestidos en día después estábamos
trabajando bajo el flujo de time para
poder terminar a tiempo y la desgracia
ocurrió afortunadamente no afectó a
nadie
golpeó a muy pocas personas es un
milagro hemos hecho una mesa con una
oración para cristianos y musulmanes
para agradecerle a la mano invisible que
nos salvó a todos
[Música]
con todas las responsabilidades que
tenemos con nuestros empleados nuestros
clientes
preparamos rápidamente nuestros talleres
y el edificio
[Música]
y al cabo de dos semanas regresamos a
trabajar normalmente como todos los días
usted demostró una extraordinaria
resiliencia sabe la resiliencia para
nosotros los libaneses es una cosa
normal es algo que recorre nuestras
venas apoyaremos nuestro país hasta el
final
debido a la pandemia se volvió imposible
desfilar en parís para los diseñadores
de prêt à para usted a como muchos de
sus colegas el isaf se volcó hacia la
comunicación digital hizo películas en
las montañas cercanas a beirut en cuanto
a su colección de alta costura la
modificó totalmente tras la catástrofe
del 4 de agosto
la colección no debo transformar la
colección y hacer algo como homenaje a
mi país es por ello que empecé a
trabajar en beirut fuente eterna porque
yo sigo viendo a virus como una ciudad
radiante una ciudad como una semilla y
es por ello que transformé toda la
dulzura de la vida que estaba en la otra
colección en una colección un poco más
real
más deslumbrante para mostrar la belleza
de mi ciudad y cómo me gustaría verla
siempre
vayan
hay que decir que merecemos una vida una
vida normal queremos una vida normal
cada libanés piensa en muchas cosas para
resistir en beirut
o mérito y normal o normal como los que
tenemos aquí van podemos a poquitos
este abrupto
a pesar de los 15 años de guerra civil
las crisis de muchas naturalezas la moda
del virus hace brillar el país es un
orgullo nacional generadora de empleos
pero el estado libanés deficiente
provoca el agotamiento de los más
fuertes es un poco una negación tratamos
de vivir con ello es nuestra fuerza en
nuestra debilidad a la vez debilidad
porque
porque nos engañan siempre los tiene
atrapados en un estado mafioso una
envergadura mafiosa internacional y
estamos entrampados logran conseguir
materias primas
logramos conseguir todo eso cuando
contamos con los recursos podemos
obtener todo lo que queramos logramos
comprar lo que necesitamos en el
extranjero no pretendemos bajar de nivel
de calidad lo que hacemos
es cierto que hay más lentitud en cuanto
a la producción incluso en el extranjero
buceo ariguaní italia o en francia ante
los productores están más lentos estás
como nosotros pero golpeados de manera
distinta también les cuesta avanzar
hay cosas que ya no pueden producir no
cuentan con suficientes pedidos nos
adaptamos creamos con lo que hay
para que clientes las galas de caridad
los matrimonios los vals y fiestas de
cualquier tipo han sido aplazadas los
vestidos se quedan en los armarios los
pedidos se acumulan en los stocks los
diseñadores de moda también son
empresarios a los que les cuesta cerrar
sus presupuestos
incluso durante la cuarentena que
estuvimos cerrados el estado libanés nos
obligó a pagar totalmente la seguridad
social y si no paga lo sancionan con 12%
de intereses
pero lo entiendo
porque lo necesitan necesitan dinero
líquido el país está quebrado
en cuanto a los jóvenes diseñadores en
2017 justo después de culminar sus
estudios joya that obtuvo el primer
premio de la fashion week de beirut con
su colección orquídea sangrienta una
recordación del coraje la fuerza el
aguante de las mujeres la catástrofe del
4 de agosto acabó con su resistencia se
exilió a white y lanzó a lo digital como
usted sabe debido al comité trabajamos
desde casa entonces cuando la gente
quiere comprar todo se volvió online
ecommerce y dubai está tomando esas
direcciones de una manera muy exitosa
hasta cierto punto regresará a beirut
algún día espero cuando esté lista con
mucho orgullo volvería a beirut
quedarse irse volver una crisis
existencial que no para
[Música]